[Musique]
josée legault michel c'est roger luc
ferrandez bon soit il
fallait quand même être fait seul et
vous allez passer la remarque pour
écouter ça d'un très fière ce débat en
français les candidats à la chefferie du
parti conservateur du canada il ya des
bouts peu surréaliste mais il ya eu des
extraits intéressant je vous fais tout
de suite en temps ce la maison qui me
qui n'était pas l' écoute un extrait sur
la loi et l'ordre monsieur charest qui
attaquent monsieur poilievre sur la
sphère des camionneurs en dire vous avez
vous avez laissé faire ça vous allez
vous les avez encouragé main et la
réponse de monsieur poilievre nico
c'est un peu ironique d'entendre
monsieur paul yeves faire la morale sur
la loi et l'ordre lui qui a soutenu un
blocus illégal à ta voix alors que
monsieur charest je me souviens de la
commission charbonneau hockey
[Applaudissements]
et les québécois se souviennent aussi
les camionneurs n'ont aucune leçon à
apprendre de vous par rapport à la loi
et l'ordre
le bilinguisme suis poli m c'est dire la
même chose au canada anglais qu'au
canada est ce que j'ai fait
et en inde la question est la suivante à
monsieur paul y est il le dit au québec
que si la loi 21 allait il sent français
elle à la cour suprême du canada vers ne
m'allait pas intervenir je m'excuse il
n'a jamais dit la même chose au canada
anglais alors est double 1 où les ports
et non c'est pas vrai j'ai peur je me
suis prononcé contre la loi 21 ici au
québec en français et je me suis
prononcé contre la voie le 21 partout au
pays la sélection il se barre parce que
les éléphants s'il vous plaît entre
fonctions et laissé une telle loi était
présenté devant la chambre des communes
ont je vois cette allocation et
vous avez eu l'essentiel du débat
mesdames et messieurs et sur la loi et
l'ordre et sur la loi 21 ça c'est
colletailler pas mal entre monsieur
charest se poilievre et monsieur brown
en fait tout le monde attaque et
monsieur poilievre hier
1er tour de table josée legault est ce
que pour les militants conservateurs est
ce que monsieur charest
s'est montré sur son meilleur jour et
est ce que ça rend la course peut-être
davantage imprévisible qu'elle ne
l'était
plus imprévisible ce ne sais pas mais
c'est sûr que monsieur charest disons
pour la première fois apparaissait plus
allumé on ne trouvait plus tôt était
jusqu'à maintenant il était évidemment
sur son propre territoire était à la
baguette au québec c'était en français
quoique tout aussi à l'aise en anglais
mais on voyait qu'il avait vraiment pris
du tonus et en plus il avait
cette espèce de numéros coordonnées ou
pas de bon cop bad cop avec patrick
brown qui lui s'en prenait très dur mais
monsieur poyet même si en principe
c'était très difficile de comprendre ce
qu'il disait mais vraiment ça fait une
équipe mais pour pour la suite des
choses c'est un contrôle ou un drapeau
pour savoir si monsieur poilievre son
avance et un prêt d'être grugés vraiment
très bien
elle vous êtes là oui vous êtes là je
vous votre fonction décidément ce soir
on a tous bien chez luc
et sur la loi et l'ordre et loi 21 est
ce que quelqu'un a marqué des points où
on a que répéter de manière plus
agressive qu on avait déjà entendu oui
on a juste répété mais il faut dire que
monsieur charest a fait précéder son
intervention ce par des
déclarations sur l'alourdissement des
peines qu'ils voulaient imposer à
plusieurs catégories de criminels don
qui s'inscrit vraiment dans la tradition
conservatrice de la loi et l'ordre avec
l'alourdissement des peines
ceci étant dit monsieur poilievre ne dit
pas grand chose monsieur paul hier se
contentent d'attaqué puisqu'il veut si
décrédibiliser monsieur charest
notamment il évoque par exemple mais là
puis monsieur charest au registre des
armes à feu c'est son seul objectif il
ne définit pas ces politiques ne dit pas
ce qu'il va faire il fait juste
décrédibiliser chat reste et sa façon de
jouer de gagner la course bon je fais
rendez vous c'est quand même où elle
exige aux et non les jeux mais c'est
quand même passé quelque chose
d'intéressant entre autres c'est
justement à la position sur la loi 21 on
a vu pierre poilievre et jean charest se
ranger le même jour la pétition de
justin trudeau c'est à dire que bon s'il
devenait chef du parti conservateur une
fois joe e aussi disons se joindre à la
contestation de la loi devant devant la
cour suprême où watsco envers le
procureur général pour pour s'exprimer
et est donc en même temps ce que ça
voulait dire c'est que larguer des
ralliements de françois legault pas ce
que c'était c'était ses derniers alliés
sur la scène fédérale avoir le coeur
bien entendu et on a vu que la sortie
plus tôt dans la journée de justin
trudeau et du mini statistiques la
justice david les métiers dans ce
sens-là avait vraiment fait mouche la et
sa place et messieurs poilievre echard
est dans une position vraiment intenable
ils ont dû sortir parce que si j'avais
pris une position différente de celle du
premier ministre au canada anglais il
aurait pris
poilievre une certaine rage mais c est
monsieur charest attaqué monsieur
poilievre là dessus on l'a entendu en 10
ans au canada anglais vous dit pas la
même chose qu'au québec vous dit au
québec vous laissez entendre comme
l'orgue aller haut débit les le deal
qu'il irait il le forcer et d'ailleurs
il y au réalignement envers les
politiques qu'on avait changé un peu
pour entre guillemets amadouer le québec
le luxe et comme eu un recentrage
oui monsieur poilievre dans sa première
visite au québec est apparu comme
personne très sympathique complètement
différente de la personne qu'on connaît
en chambre ou dans les débats en alberta
notamment et monsieur charest voulait
casser cette image là il voulait dire
attention ce n'est pas la personne que
vous pensez qu'il est c'est une personne
agressive qui attaquent constamment de
québec lorsqu'il n'est pas au québec et
je pense que la russie mais il a été
aidé par monsieur labati va
effectivement monsieur poilievre a plus
le choix n'avait plus le choix que de se
ranger derrière cette idée qui a partout
au canada anglais selon laquelle le
fédéral doit monter au créneau doit
défendre les canadiens contre la loi 21
on a vraiment l'impression que beaucoup
de gens aux partis
sont devenus et peur et on perd un peu
du phénomène poilievre autant il remplit
les salles puis il ya un phénomène on a
parlé à plusieurs reprises ici autant ce
qu'il dit depuis deux trois semaines et
sur la banque du canada sur davos sur la
crypto monnaie il ya des gens
conservateur qui commence à dire est-ce
qu'il a du jugement et hier c'était
frappant de voir que tous les candidats
l'ont attaqué personne ne l'a aidé et
c'était charest tous les autres quand
monsieur poilievre josé
oui mais s'il ya une inquiétude dans les
rangs conservateurs
on se demande vraiment où elle est à
part dans ce qui est de l'appel de la
petite aile progressiste conservatrice
là parce que monsieur poêle et y est
messieurs poil hier via reste pas moins
que son positionnement sur le soi-disant
convoi de la liberté à l'huile les
camionneurs les camionneurs
qu'on passera là dessus la haie quand
même eu des organisateurs qui ont été
accusés encourent donc ce n'est pas
seulement une occupation illégale mais
il ya eu il ya eu des gestes illégaux de
poser aussi par plusieurs des
manifestants
c'est déjà là c'était connu bien avant
et les espèces de position un peu
délirante qui l'a prise par la suite que
vous venez de d'énumérer ça ne fait que
nourrir c'est ce même positionnement la
droite très dure que trois pistes bon
peut-être et du corps et un peu à la
canadienne et c'est ce que disait jean
charest à la fin quand il ya décroché de
cette excitation d'être pseudo
américaine c'était le message qu'il
envoyait mais jusqu'à maintenant ça peut
changer mais jusqu'à maintenant ça plaît
une partie importante de la mesure du
parti conservateur qui s'appelait on a
l'impression que ça le fringant mais on
va montrer des chiffres sondages à
bacchus qui montrent que monsieur
charest a pris quelques points monsieur
charest poilievre chez les canadiens
tous les canadiens donc 32 % 26
poilievre mais chez les partisans du pc
cible c'est eux qui votent évidemment
plus 3 monsieur charest et -4 monsieur
paul est bon bien sûr l'avant insu
poilievre michel serre bonsoir est
encore très grande mais on a
l'impression que c'est ce qui va arriver
ce qui est arrivé avec quelqu'un ball
mais l'impression monsieur charest ta
train de remonter tranquillement sur
poyet d'entrée le dessin qu'est ce qui
va arriver on le sait pas mais
c'est un concours d'abord et avant tout
jusqu'à maintenant debout mad about de 4
demain et ça on n'a pas d'indication
tout ça sans avoir un ultime et
l'édification par l'argent que les
candidats récoltes et ça pour ça ça vaut
mieux changer dit-on mais la réalité
c'est que on sait pas comment les la
vente de cartes de membres se produit
dans chacun dans chacun et s'ils sont
pas si on avance que ça du côté de
monsieur poignard mais en même temps ce
conduit r c'est dit-il groupe et
contrepoids hier c'est donc leur sérieux
nous appelle à chacun des autres
candidats m'ont dit mais c'est normal à
battre c'est lui qui est en avance et je
note aussi que ce poignant parle plus de
la banque du canada il va au cul de ne
pas envoyer de ministre a d'abord parce
que c'est trop dangereux
ces gens là de voir cette s'est alors
lui est déjà prêt de faire son virage
vers le centre est ce que le danger pour
lui en fait c est des gens qui sont
ralliés à lui très tôt parce qu'il était
capable justement de
d'incarner cette droite dure l'appui
des partisans à ce que le monde urbain
monde où ce qui est en train de devenir
comme les autres mais
jusqu'à preuve du contraire les
conservateurs ont l'air de vouloir leur
promet
il faut que monsieur et madame ou et
alizée josé da luz où et quand ces mêmes
lorsqu'il est sorti pro-choix hier de
manière plus claire donc ou l'hébreu
soit l'avortement
parmi ces appuyons beaucoup dans ce
choix alors ils sont aussi est-ce qu'il
va y avoir un petit
oui oui mais c'était c'était tellement
un clairière et céder là aussi c'est
monsieur charest qui est allé chercher
le ticket le monde le disait car le
libre-choix mais il disait pas pro choix
effectivement il disait je suis pour la
liberté de man il joue sur les mots
mais c'est moi je pense que monsieur
points je pense que les les dés sont il
n'y a pas de bonnes ya pas de bonnes
mains de pour des partis conservateurs
soit poilievre fait de lui un maxime
bernier c'est à dire il s'attache à ces
idées extravagantes sur la pente canada
qui la crypto monnaie et et autres et il
va faire de lui un maxime bernier c'est
à dire quelqu'un qui va rester
éternellement dans l'opposition mais qui
vont représenter la colère de certains
conservateurs soit monsieur charest
deviez un geste une can i c'est à dire
qui prend la tête du parti conservateur
parce que les gens réalisent que avec
poilievre ça serait trop radical mais il
va se faire chambouler par sa propre
droite d'ici quelques années c'est à
dire que comme jason kenny qui avait
réussi à réunir le plus parti
conservateur mais qui se fait mettre
dehors par les éléments les plus
radicaux sont partis
sur le long du chemin alors ce ne sont
pas des bonnes cartes ni pour l'un ni
pour l'autre et l'autre question qu'on
peut se poser sexy rouleau gagne est ce
que lol tu vas rester parce qu'on
imagine mal bien sûr monsieur charest va
pas rester jusqu'à entre indique serait
candidat pour un député mais ce qu'il
représente comment peu peuvent cohabiter
ces deux factions là les plus
progressistes conservateurs et ce que
représente monsieur poilievre hier on a
rarement vu en politique canadienne des
échanges aussi acrimonieux ou si
agressif que ça josy les lendemains non
seulement sont difficiles mais vont être
divisif
mais moi je pense qu'il a été possible
je le répète je pense qu'on assiste à un
schisme cc monsieur charest monsieur
poyet mme représentent ces schistes
molosses c'est à dire finalement un
retour à l'ère prix harper lorsqu'il y
avait un parti progressiste conservateur
moribond et et l'alliance canadienne de
stephen harper beaucoup plus forte et
c'est l'alliance canadienne que vous
fait le parti progressiste conservateur
donc messieurs un peu il y avait le
pouvoir qui s'en venait il y avait des
libéraux qui baisse c'est y'avait
scandale des commandites
il y avait vraiment il y avait l'odeur
du pouvoir pour réunir aussi ces gens là
le yard n'a pas d'odeur du pouvoir là
monsieur trudeau s'est assurée avec
monsieur singh d'une alliance qui va
regarder les libéraux pour au moins
jusqu'en 2025 et cissé poilievre ben
écoutez c'est cette année c'est à des
milles et des milles de la majorité de
l'électorat canadien qui skie votre
comportement c'est un prix cela dans les
faits donc non moi je pense que ces gens
là ils peuvent pas se rappeler ces c'est
trop tard c'est terminé ce qu'on voit
sur la scène ça c'est ce qui est public
c'est ce qui est promis alors imaginez
ce qui change dans les coulisses de
shine et beaucoup de mépris il ya
beaucoup d'agressivité beaucoup
d'agressivité c'est pas beau c'est
presque pire que des bocks même quand
rampe était là pour les pour les chez
les républicains michel on n'a pas vu ça
souvent le niveau d'agressivité
non et c'est dû à deux choses d'abord la
personnalité de monsieur poil hier qui
clivent 1 c'est quelqu'un qui vit là
dessus donc et d'autre part monsieur
charles ix qui lui joue son va tout
sylvie et chef du parti conservateur ça
sera le couronnement de sa carrière
sinon ils symptômes chez eux dans le
secteur privé qui il va être ils vont
être très bien quand même il n'a pas
réussi son rêve mais quand même monsieur
charest est clair que s'il n'est pas
cher qui sera pas candidat conservateur
aux élections kouadio jeannot à faire
alors la combinaison des deux fait
quelque chose qui fait beaucoup de flou
match mais à la fin personne ne
s'appelle est ce que jean charest ce
soit sur les rangs s'il ne gagne pas
l'élection les autres c'est autre chose
alors on va dans ce que ça donne mais ça
donne une situation assez assez assez
différentes des corsos d'une logique
habituelle ou poyer
on peut parler de la foule est ce qu'on
peut parler des gens qui étaient qui
sont venus parce que dans les éléments
qu'il faut ajouter il faut ajouter cette
foule extrêmement bruyante qui chahutent
qui encourage comme certaines parties de
hockey et qui a l'air est directement en
partie directement issues des rats très
très très militaire et ça aussi ça va
jouer ce sont des gens qui pour qui la
colère est plus importante que le
pouvoir et je pense qu'ils veulent
exprimer d'abord et avant tout le
résignation leur frustration leur
persécution et leur colère colère plus
important que le pouvoir ne fait un
panel vendredi soir sur le la droite
canadienne justement qu'ils étaient
davantage réactionnaire plutôt que
conservatrice en ce moment à avoir ok je
vous fais coûte un autre extrait sur le
français parce qu'on peut pas ne pas en
parler il y avait deux des bords y avait
ce charme ce poilievre qui se branche
qui se débrouille quand même et il y
avait
il y avait des fois des sketches presque
de paul et paul il y avait un effort là
il y avait un enfant il y avait leur
feuille jeu on reconnaît tout le monde a
reconnu les fourrières mais quand même
malaise sont ni connu
je dois les trois derniers je me levais
à presque tout maintenant quand leçons
de français à 7h messieurs paul yeves et
un serveur de l'argent numérique pour se
protéger contre
l'inflation les imériens de nous aider à
créer des collectifs et diversifiée à
faire croître notre économie et à bâtir
un canada meilleur quand pierre dit que
tu peux éliminer le l'infraction avec le
big one c'est étrange et si si les
parents et les grands-parents écouter à
son avis et vert cordes et verts perdent
leurs feuilles ans et c'est
je ne comprends pas ce qu'ils pensent
et brown c'est c'est le maire c'est nos
amis des mordus qui ont fait ce montage
là ce midi long perdre leurs filiales ou
non
y arriver sais pas si vous vous souvenez
oui c'est possible vous souvenez de ce
personnage dans les bleu poudre de des
vaches là ouais américain qui peuplaient
phrases et moi c'était ça ces petits des
vaches
qu'est-ce que ça n'indique en forme et
blanc qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça en dit
long oui mais ça en dit long sur la
marginalisation du prince est rendu à
des postes quand même aussi ambitieux
que ça ces gens allaient à part les deux
messieurs charest ne suis pas ya dix ans
ambitionne de diriger un parti national
il ambitionne après de devenir premier
ministre première ministre et écoutez
c'est même pas du risque au french comme
on dit là c'est même poste alors c'est
non c'est vraiment les oreilles seigneur
seigneur ouais c'est pas que c'est un
michel
le parti conservateur et b en faisant ce
débat là et il aurait été possible on
est dans du lait en 2020 de dire non il
ya des candidats vingt deux des quinze
candidats qui ne seront pas admis au
débat parce qu'on a le niveau de
français n'est pas correct je ne sais
pas qui a dit ça aujourd'hui je trouvais
que c'était exactement comme ça que je
me suis senti c'est bon c'est comme
regarder un bon film avec une pause
subissent elles ont 45 secondes parce qu
avez-vous compris de quoi il
s'est dit triste mais c'est exactement
comme ça c'est exactement comme ça que
je me suis senti quand j'entends du jeu
mais voilà je demande aux jeunes
cherchent un verre d'eau pourquoi mais
il ya pis des mollahs ya juste juste du
bruit et ça rend l'exercice
à plusieurs moments dans la soirée
enfantin c'est que c'est tellement c'est
tellement sympa ce qu'il faut qui lisent
le lit on avance 0 dans le débat on n'a
fait que faire du surplace l'udc
qu'avez vous pensé du français mais je
vous et de partager ce que josé et
michel
il n'y a rien d'autre à dire que ce soit
csa ce faisant ils n'avaient pas il
n'aurait pas dû à monter sur scène c'est
pas compliqué et c'est drôle parce que
les conservateurs un plus radicaux ont
découvert des québécois lord les grandes
manifs à voter à wade camionneurs parce
que j'avais des drapeaux canadiens à
profusion et tu t'écoutes induit
beaucoup de drapeaux québécois et les
les camionneurs galles canadiens se sont
montrés surpris et de manifestants
qu'elle se montre surpris d'avoir à il
ya une aile plus radicale québécoise et
l'on a senti une volonté de
rapprochement mais en quelques mois
c'est pas assez pour apprendre le
français donc
c'est lamentable
ok on va on va se quitter sur
je le dire nouvelle réjouissante l'un
d'eux est fou
on parle d' aide médicale à mourir mais
on le québec donc élargis on a enlevé le
l'article qui faisait problème parce que
dernière minute le gouvernement avait
encore plus élargie mais là on a élargi
aux gens les gens pourront signer un
papier dans six mois je me retourne à
telle situation je veux l'aide médicale
à mourir dans des conditions humaines
etc c'est un dans quelle mesure c'est un
pas important tour de table là dessus
avant de se dire aurevoir josé
cc pour moi j'ai je respecte les gens
qui en fou qui ont vraiment défendu
cette cause mais j'ai un gros malaise je
ne sais pas comment les médecins comme
les familles vont appliquer ça le moment
venu mais
je suis tout à fait favorable à l'aide
médicale à mourir mais là on entre dans
des eaux
beaucoup plus complexes assure le plein
michel
c'est effectivement très complexe mais
sur la question jenny dégénératives
comme l'alzheimer je pense qu'il y avait
un gros ça se sait il est des sociale et
les gens qui ont eu à vivre ça dans leur
famille dit un moment donné au pas ou
mal en plus haut mais je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui devrait quand même sur
ce point alors bien marché n'était pas
tragique piqûre ça c'est une autre
histoire il faudra faire à peu près des
bonnes actions ouais ça a été retiré sa
nuque de noix nazis qui est incurable et
qui
pour lequel bienvenue ainsi rassurer qui
est là à quelques la mort mais aussi
l'incapacité pour la personne qui en
souffre de prendre une décision au
moment où elle en souffre le plus donc
elle ne peut pas décidé d'abréger sa vie
en fin de vie parce qu'elle n'a plus les
capacités intellectuelles pour le faire
donc la loi actuelle dit tu dois te voir
te prononcer deux fois au moins deux
fois pour avoir l'aide à mourir alors ça
me semble tout à fait logique de dire
ces personnes-là voudrait sans doute de
faire non plus les moyens de le faire on
va leur donner le choix de le faire à
l'avance merci beaucoup merci à vous
trois bonne soirée on se reparle bientôt
on va pouvoir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit